had it not been for rt there's a whole
host of stories out of europe that you
may well have a very different view on
from the dramatic
greek debt standoff that shook the eu to
its core
we brought you not only the views of
brussels and athens bureaucracy
but also of those bearing the brunt from
the front lines of their fight
we've seen violent clashes here in the
center of athens
greece has seen a marked increase in
support for
far-right and neo-nazi groups while
greece was being punished for its
bailouts with austerity
we looked at the way switzerland was
aiming to change the way
wealth inequality was handled
cash by the truckload the proposed basic
income initiative arrived with a splash
and the promise of 2 000 euro a month
for every swiss
citizen intended to let them live
without basic financial worry
while people were making dangerous
journeys to come here from
war-torn parts of the world here at rt
we
met those people coming to europe and
looked at why their home
countries had been made so unsafe
well this beach is one that's used as a
regular arrival ground for refugees
coming from syria
afghanistan and elsewhere so there were
60 people
in that boat in a boat
i think actually it could take 20 people
but
there were 60. we were also among the
first to see the political and social
consequences of mass migration
and the rise of those who did not
welcome it
this is a group derided by their critics
as
far-right extremists some have even
called them
neo-nazis they however say that they're
against radical islam and are defending
europe against what they see
as the islamification of the continent
some things have stayed the same over
the years
[Music]
we've also been at the forefront of new
innovations
changing lives and on occasion asking
just because we could
does that always mean that we should
so this gentleman here selling one
bitcoin for 85 euro that's correct
that's correct okay and if this
continues pretty soon bitcoins might not
be only for nerds
they could be the cash jingling in all
our pockets we weren't the only ones
watching of course
it's a question germans have been
wanting answers to since the summer of
how much are they being spied on but it
has been fun along the way
these days more and more people are
concerned where their food has come from
but for some just because you like pork
chops doesn't mean you want to come face
to face
with the pig this bag here contains
around three grams
of plastic explosive and i'm going to go
and hide somewhere here in the terminal
while fraga tries to track me down
[Music]
sure enough she finds me trying to check
in for a flight
well done good job got me even if not
all of the decisions from my side
have been the best i don't know what i
was thinking with that beard
with greece having being in arrears to
the international monetary fund
and not having any bailout money with no
bailout on the horizon
as it stands anyway thanks for being
with us
for the last 15 years from all of the
team here
in the german capital i'm peter oliver
for rt
in berlin
you